one of the
easiest activities to do
is to become aware of
when you do not fixate
another way of saying this is become
aware of the silence between the notes
so if you have a chain of thought
and you're bouncing between
thoughts and all of a sudden you notice
that space when there's no
thought between two thoughts
it's like the silence between the notes
and then if you can focus
your attention on the silence between
the notes
when there's no fixation when there's
nothing
grasping this
is typically what is called becoming
aware of awareness
or becoming aware of pure consciousness
when it's bare and fundamentally
unfixated
when it's non-modulated
it's like the empty screen
when there's not an application that's
on it when you're not browsing the
internet
it's just the powered off screen
without a modulation and so if you
become aware of that space between the
notes if you become aware
of how you can perpetually practice like
a muscle
train your ability to break the chain
of thoughts and then land on this
empty spaciousness like the silence
between the notes
you'll feel a feeling of being unblocked
you'll feel a feeling of emptiness
you'll feel
freedom you'll feel peace you'll feel a
non-identification
and typically the breath is used as the
tool that
helps you remember this so like right
now
freedom
just not jumping between thoughts and
rather
just feeling that space of freedom of
silence
of emptiness
and then becoming more accustomed to
tapping into that space
because you'll notice that your
conditioned responses dissolve
so that you won't
be so habitually overlooking
consciousness or awareness
and be focused on the attributes
or the thought clouds or
the beliefs or the emotions but instead
you'll be focused on
awareness itself or consciousness or
beingness itself
i am-ness itself and that feeling will
expand
outward more and more to encompass more
people more interactions the whole
planet the whole universe
you'll slowly merge more and more with
that
and thoughts and conditioned responses
will have less control over you your
awareness is becoming less
less fixated
you're perpetually breaking the chain of
thinking of emotion of behavior of
pattern
that is causing you to suffer because
you want to force your point of view
into a conversation
or you're incessantly jumping between
things that you have to do
this is where the buddha field of
compassion opens up because when
you end up decentralizing your identity
to the entire cosmos the only thing
that's left is to feel this compassion
for the rest of life to awaken to not
suffering
to awaken to harmony to happiness to joy
to peace
to abundance and flourishing
and so the amount that you
decrease your conditioned responses
is proportionately equal to the amount
of
radiant compassion that you emit
and another way to say this is the
nettie nettie method of not this not
that
where you stay in a perpetual state of
not being grasped
by the attributes you become ungraspable
so even when something does arise that
you just watch it
disappear without becoming grasped by it
and spending a minute or two minutes or
ruminating in that thought pattern
incessantly
or when somebody says something
whether a compliment or an insult or
something that you have to do or
something that you didn't do
that you'll watch that arise and then
dissolve into emptiness and then you'll
come
from a place of that merged state
with the god son the universal beingness
so then you don't respond to the
stimuli from your conditioning but you
respond to it from a place of love and
wisdom
compassion which is the real
intelligence
so the more that you become ungrasped by
attributes
the more that you perpetually feel
disidentified with
the dance that is occurring with
thoughts and beliefs and emotions and
separate people talking to other
separate people but you abide more and
more
in the truth of the universal i
am-ness the god state
where your awareness is unfixed but it's
just
relaxed
and you've decentralized your identity
from the contracted subconscious
conditioning frameworks
that triggers come in and it pinballs
around between these conditioning
frameworks
to now when the trigger comes in it just
dissolves into that black hole of
emptiness
because you are just radiating out then
that god state instead of the state of
separate conditioned contracted identity
so you become more and more sovereign
you become more and more radiant of the
god state you become
less and less emitting out
an energy of separation and conditioning
and fixating your awareness on the
attributes that are constantly grasping
you as
emotions and thoughts and beliefs so
you're continuously breaking the chain
of
thinking and relaxing into the
indescribable non-tension
of the ease of being
and you're catching yourself faster and
faster
in these chains of thinking and
shattering it
into a relaxed non-tense state of just
being and so this has been called in
zolchen several times as a
samadhi bell so it's like a dong
where you go from a place of fixated
awareness and you catch yourself
and you feel this non-dual awareness you
feel that samadhi that meditative
consciousness
taken the seat
as the bell rings
and you feel indescribable peace and joy
and ease and you're not clinging
on to that samadhi bell and you're not
averting the fixations on
thoughts rather you're just becoming
aware to the process of what is
happening naturally
in evolution so you're becoming more
aware of
reality as it is
where you can now have a visual
juxtaposition between when you're in
a chain of thought clouds versus
when you recognize the silence between
the notes
and then you relax into that non-tense
state of being and that's what feels
like that bell of ease
and then from there you feel that god
son state
where everything is one intelligence at
play with itself and you come
from there instead of from the webs of
conditioning
that are buried in the subconscious that
we're not aware of
so you're gaining more will you're
unfreezing your will you're gaining more
sovereignty
you're perpetually becoming less and
less
fixated on attributes you're becoming
less
grasped clinging and craving
and averting you're becoming
more and more equanimous more peaceful
more joyful and then you're radiating
that out
your nature of being unblocked will then
help other people become
unblocked because they'll notice that
why are you not trying to shove your
point of view into the conversation
they'll just notice that you're just
there as that godson
radiating presence of love and wisdom
and they themselves will become less
blocked they themselves will see what
it's like to not force their perspective
into the conversation but rather to just
relax
and so in a sense you're automatically
doing yoga for other people as well
yoga meaning union with god
as they become less and less blocked
from that third chakra to that fourth
chakra
where they're open more to that green
energy of love at the heart center
and they'll feel more of the buddha
field of compassion opening up
they'll feel more of their conditioned
responses dissolving
and it's all based on their own
visualization of the difference between
being
caught in the egoic separation fixated
grasping state
versus being in the relaxed empty
non-tense peaceful
joyful i am state
and another way to practice
becoming aware of awareness or the
silence between the notes
is to play the know the knower game
and so in this case what i'll share
is i'll share an exercise
so i've brought this up on the show
before
where if you're using
analogies you can become
more experientially
wise with direct knowledge
of what we're talking about so if you've
never
really become that aware of awareness or
that aware of consciousness
and you don't really necessarily
understand what it means to become aware
of something that's formless
then what i would do is i would start
with these ping pong balls
as we talk about knowing the knower what
does it mean to become aware of the
witness or that which is observing
reality
well the eyeballs are a really good way
to start
so you can take this ping pong ball
analogy
and you can visualize these ping pong
balls
in the place of your eyeballs
and so you visualize these ping-pong
balls in the place of your eyeballs
and then what you do is you're trying to
become
aware of the fact that you're
aware you're trying to become aware of
the fact that you're
conscious more and more via direct
experience
so can you become aware that you have
these eyeballs
and that you're literally able to see
how profound is it that you're able to
see how profound is it that you have
this capacity to know
that you have this power to know and so
when you become more and more
intimately connected with this again
formless
power to know you become more and more
directly
experientially aware of awareness
so this is a good way to sort of move
yourself from
focusing on all of the objects and
perceptions
and sensations and beliefs and emotions
and the chain of thinking
to becoming aware of the formless state
of
just pure bear empty
consciousness itself pure bear
empty awareness that is unfixated so
it's not
fixating on things it's not being
grasped
by attributes but instead it's just
relaxing as its very
formless nature
peacefully joyfully and so you can use
analogies like this
because when was the last time in your
life that you
ever really became aware of the
profundity of your eyeballs and the
profundity of the power to know
very rarely if ever
and so this is a good way to draw your
attention away
from the clouds of thinking emotions
and objects towards the very power to
know
towards consciousness or awareness when
it's not fixated
so use analogies like these and help
your friends family kids use analogies
like these to become more and more aware
of the power to know
and so another way of
viewing
this power of unfixated awareness
is to recognize that
what's happening is that the mind which
is perpetually
fixating it's perpetually grasping on
these attributes
is exactly what is hiding you from
uniting with the kingdom of god
infinity that is located right
here and now the absolute is what you
are
but the mind is hiding the absolute
the mind is hiding the kingdom of god
the mind is hiding your nature
as indescribable absolute infinity
and so most simply put you have
the state of mind which is very much
like an animal state
it's like a scripted limbal state
limbic state so the mind is like an
animal
scripted limbic primal
state of being where you're perpetually
fixating you're perpetually grasping
and then you have the state of god
realization which is typically
when you become aware of the formless
kingdom
which is awareness or consciousness or
love
and then you recognize that
there are two sides to the same coin
that are beyond
the power to know which is absolute
nothingness
and absolute infinity
and you become more and more comfortable
with knowing yourself
after 10 trillion years will be
absolutely traceless
at the same time as knowing that this
manifestation is just one expression of
infinite possibility which is your
truest nature
and then you transcend all of those
levels into just
this most natural state
of
just indescribability because you've
actually
become united with the essence of what
it means to
truly be alive
to be alive
while truly knowing
what it means to be alive
because you can be alive
as a separate egoic finite
creature on a rock or you can be alive
knowing yourself as the indescribable
absolute infinite intelligence
that is at play with itself via these
creations
and so this is it guys it really breaks
down
this simply just shatter that chain of
thinking
silence between the notes unfixated
awareness
feeling more empty unblocked
unidentified
all your conditioned responses slowly
dissolve the buddha field of compassion
opens up you're being less and less
grasped by attributes you're becoming
more and more
aware of the knower itself of this god
realized state
and just recognizing that the mind is
what has been hiding you
from infinity it's been hiding you from
the pure essence
of all possibility which is the most
essential
fundamental aspect to the nature of
reality
beautiful so practice this process of
knowing the knower practice this process
of knowing the silence between
the chains of thought practice this
process of
shattering the chains of thought
practice this process of that beautiful
samadhi bell
non-dual awareness non-grasped
non-fixated
just empty just beautifully
unidentified just helping
feel that buddha compassion nature that
then
emanates outward like the sunlight in
service pure service
i hope this was helpful for you i'd love
for you to leave a comment below with
where you're at in the process
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe to the channel
if you haven't already and also share
the video with people that you feel like
this would be
impactful for that's all infinite love
thank you
be free my friends be free